recall that you can click on the
timestamp in the description to skip
this intro it's generally beneficial to
speak to one another live as facial
expressions and vocal tonality convey
much that's lost over text especially
text that's limited to a certain amount
of characters that's one of the reasons
for today's theo locution with sabine
haasenfelder and bernardo castro as the
medium of twitter has one's twitter
following requesting bloodshed however
truculence pales in comparison to
congenial mutual constructiveness and
the latter is which theolocutions are or
at least what they are at their best
sabina hossenfelder is a theoretical
physicist researching quantum gravity as
well as having the ever elucidating
youtube channel sabina hostenfelder link
in the description as well as being a
researcher one of the prime researchers
in super determinism super determinism
is what brings us here today at least
thematically and at most inevitably if
the theory is to be believed bernardo
castro is the executive director of the
essentia foundation all links are in the
description by the way bernardo is one
of the most cogent champions of
metaphysical idealism the view that
reality is essentially mental put
forward with the analytical precision
imbued in him from his phd in philosophy
and computer engineering click on the
time stamp in the description if you'd
like to skip this intro my name is
kirchey mungle i'm a torontonian
filmmaker with a background in
mathematical physics dedicated to the
explication of the variegated terrain of
theories of everything from a
theoretical physics perspective but as
well as analyzing consciousness and
seeing its potential connection to
fundamental reality whatever that is
essentially this channel is dedicated to
exploring the under nature of reality
the constitutional laws that govern it
provided those laws exist at all and are
even noble to us if you enjoy witnessing
and engaging with others on the topics
of psychology consciousness physics etc
the channels themes then do consider
going to the discord and the subreddit
which are linked in the description
there's also a link to the patreon that
is patreon.com slash kirchheim uncle if
you'd like to support this podcast as
the patrons and the sponsors are the
only reasons that i'm able to have
podcasts of this quality and this depth
given that i can do this now full time
thanks to both the patrons and the
sponsors support speaking of sponsors
there are two the first sponsor is
brilliant during the winter break i
decided to brush up on some of the
fundamentals of physics particularly
with regard to information theory as i'd
like to interview chiara marletto on
constructor theory which is heavily
based in information theory now
information theory is predicated on
entropy at least there's a fundamental
formula for entropy so i ended up taking
the brilliant course i challenged myself
to do one lesson per day and i took the
course's random variable distributions
and knowledge slash uncertainty what i
loved is that despite knowing the
formula for entropy which is essentially
hammered into you as an undergraduate it
seems like it comes down from the sky
arbitrarily and with brilliance for the
first time i was able to see how the
formula for entropy which you're seeing
right now is actually extremely natural
and it'd be strange to define it in any
other manner there are plenty of courses
and you can even learn group theory
which is what's being referenced when
you hear that the standard model is
predicated on u1 cross su 2 cross su 3
those are lead groups continuous lead
groups visit brilliant.org
toetoe to get 20 off an annual
subscription and i recommend that you
don't stop before four lessons i think
you'll be greatly surprised at the ease
at which you can now comprehend subjects
you previously had a difficult time
grocking the second sponsor is algo now
algo is an end-to-end supply chain
optimization software company with
software that helps business users
optimize sales and operations planning
to avoid stockouts reduce return and
inventory write-downs while reducing
inventory investment it's a supply chain
ai that drives smart roi headed by amjad
hussein who's been a huge supporter of
this podcast since near its inception in
fact amjad has his own podcast on ai and
consciousness and business growth and if
you'd like to support the tow podcast
then visit the link in the description
to see amjad's podcast because
subscribing to him or at least visiting
supports the toe podcast indirectly
thank you and enjoy we should be live
if you can see this
please type in
dexter's lab
dexter's lab
you're saying that to us
to the audience to the live chat if you
can see this type in dexter's lab
so sabina why don't you start with an
overview of what super determinism is
for people who
perhaps aren't as acquainted as you are
okay so
super determinism isn't really a theory
it's a property of a class of theories
which you find in the foundations of
quantum mechanics
and they are designed to solve a problem
which is the measurement problem
uh in quantum mechanics more precisely
the problem is that in quantum mechanics
we have
an evolution law for the wave function
which is the schrodinger equation that
everybody who's listening has probably
heard of and then we have the update of
the wave function which is sometimes
called the collapse or the reduction of
the wave function and
this update is non-local which means
it's not compatible with einstein's
theory of general relativity
and now there are several ways people
try to wiggle out of this one and that's
probably the most popular one at the
moment is to say well it's just not a
physical process we're just updating our
knowledge about something let's not ask
about what because that's where the
problem starts
and um that has its own problems uh one
of which is that it doesn't actually
tell us
what's happening physically like i mean
we have to put something there if we
want to take the expectation value of
something so just what is it that
locally happens so it's compatible with
general relativity the other problem
with this idea of updating knowledge uh
and
stuff like this
is that we think of quantum mechanics as
a fundamental theory that describes the
constituents of nature and that means
that
in its assumptions there shouldn't be
any macroscopic objects or other
expressions like detector observer
knowledge and that kind of thing instead
it should follow from the theory now you
may say well the obvious way to fix this
is just to replace this weird collapse
with a local process that's compatible
with um einstein's assumption of
relativity and so on
and it brings up the question like why
haven't physicists tried to do this well
the reason is that um 50 years ago or
something um they became convinced that
this isn't possible notably because of
bell's theorem so bell's theorem says
basically if you want a theory to make a
long story short that describes our
observations
um
which
is
local
like the way that we would want to have
it then it has to violate an assumption
that's called statistical independence
and that's what's called super
determinism
okay now you may wonder why the heck is
it called super determinism if it's
about violating statistical
independence and i don't know it's just
that that's what it came to be called um
a theory which
violates statistical independence
doesn't even necessarily have to be
deterministic
and
then there are a lot of philosophers who
have gone on to
claim that this requires some kind of
conspiracy that it would require us to
throw out free will and so on so it's
been loaded with this philosophical
baggage which for me as a
phenomenologist is completely irrelevant
you know the only thing i want is i want
a local theory that reproduces quantum
mechanics on the average so
oh yeah i forgot to say this so
those theories which underlie quantum
mechanics are hidden variables theories
so they say well the reason that quantum
mechanics looks uh random
non-deterministic is because there's
some information which we don't know and
those are the hidden variables and as
always i have to add that they're only
called hidden because of some historical
quirk in the nomenclature
that it doesn't mean that they are
unobservable they may at some point
become observable they're just not
present in the current formulation of
quantum mechanics
great and bernardo what are your
thoughts on that what do you agree with
and what do you disagree with perhaps we
can put this in the form of an amiable
criticism where you start with the
disagreements and then end on the
agreements
it's pretty easy to do because i i agree
with the great many things zabina just
said
and with the values that she espouses
and fights for and like her
the bernardo of today not the bernardo
20 years ago or 25 years ago but the
barnardo of today is against
metaphysical commitments in science like
the platonic commitment that built his
truth
so true theories should be beautiful and
beautiful theories should be true i got
burned very early on with the super
symmetry which we used to call susie i
don't know whether it's still called
susie but the idea is suzy is so
beautiful we all fell in love with susie
so susie needed to be true it's not at
least not in the energy ranges where we
can look with the lhc turns out it's not
true
so i think it's a good value to espouse
that science should be guided by
hard-nosed empirical evidence
not by metaphysical commitment
uh by notions of truth and beauty being
the same thing
and not by
fantasy entities like
the many worlds interpretation
or the many hyperdimensional brains and
brain collisions of m theory and all
kinds of fantasies that that are still
put forward in physics so i'm i'm right
with her
in all this point
um i do feel though that when it comes
to hidden variables
zabini
runs the risk or maybe he's already
doing it of of betraying those values
because although it may be a historical
quirk there is a good reason hidden
variables are called hidden nobody has
ever observed them now it's worse than
that nobody has ever defined them they
are not even well-formed theoretical
fantasies
nobody said what they are and how they
work the only thing that he said is well
if we want to safeguard certain
metaphysical assumptions
then there should be these variables we
don't know what they are that somehow we
don't know how do what they need to do
so we can stick to our
favorite metaphysical assumptions and in
this case
the assumption is not determinism i i am
with sabine that i want to have a
deterministic theory for single
measurements not only for ensembles i
want to predict the outcome of a single
measurement and everything we've learned
in science over the past 4 500 500 years
tells us that this should be possible
because it has always been possible up
until now
but the way to do this i think
is not to reject what 40 years of
experiments have been telling us which
is that a certain metaphysical
assumption called physical realism is
false
physical realism is the notion that
physical properties have standalone
existence that they were already there
before you measure them and that the act
of measurement simply discloses what
they already were immediately prior to
measurement
there's another technical term for this
it's known contextuality
now i think experiments have been
telling us that this is not the case
and and it's not that strange
experiments are telling us that physical
properties
appear as a product of the act of
measurement now how can we understand
this just think of an airplane cockpit
what is displayed on the dials is the
result of what the sensors outside the
airplane are measuring about the real
world outside if you don't make those
measurements there is nothing on the
dashboard the dials display nothing
nothing is there does that mean that
there is no world of course not it only
means that you are not measuring the
world and therefore you see nothing i
think what experiment is telling us is
that the physical entities we talk about
today the physical properties we talk
about today the observables of quantum
mechanics mass angular momentum charge
all those good things they are the
dashboard they are not the world as it
is in and of itself they are the way a
deeper layer of reality
presents itself to us how it presents
itself to us and therefore if we don't
measure there are no physical properties
for the same reason that the airplane
sensors don't measure the world outside
nothing is on the dashboard the physical
world is the dashboard and i think
heeding this
and understanding what nature has been
communicating to us after decades of
consistent experiments
is the way to find a deterministic
theory for single measurements
sabina what is your response and feel
free to speak directly to bernardo no
need to say bernardo or him just say
your
for example
well you've been
talking about what experiments are
telling us but how do you know what
experiments are telling us well you need
some mathematics that extracts
information from the data
and
in your interpretation you strongly rely
on certain assumptions that go into
the derivation of certain inequalities
one of this assumption is statistical
independence so if you don't have this
assumption of statistical independence
then those experiments tell you
something entirely different um
just to give a concrete example how you
can look at violations of belts
inequality and that that's also
it goes the same way for
all other kinds of inequalities really
it doesn't really matter which one is
chsh or
legates or what have you
they all make this assumption of
statistical independence so
concretely the conclusion which you can
draw from the observed violations of
those inequalities is
that
whatever is the right theory that
describes
nature must violate at least one of the
assumptions
and normally people say well we assume
that statistical independence has to be
valid
let's not ask right now why that is then
it follows that local causality has to
be violated if you on the other hand say
well we we want the theory to be local
then it follows statistical independence
has to be violated and in my mind that's
the more promising way to pursue because
as i just said
locality is fulfilled in nitrogen's
theory of general relativity and
eventually those two theories have to
communicate with each other which is
kind of a big unsolved problem blah blah
blah it can talk about this for an hour
but i assume you're uh familiar with
that
and also maybe i should before i forget
about this all this talk about
physical realism and so on and so forth
it goes past me basically because i
would say i'm an instrumentalist you
know i i care about what i can predict
with my theory if you want to call
something about this real or not real or
whatever i i'll leave this up to
philosophers
maybe on a very general level i could
say that in the hidden variables theory
the wave function itself isn't a real
thing it's some kind of an average value
it isn't any more real
than
the average person you know that's not
that's not a real thing that's a
statistical thing you can define it you
can write it down but it doesn't really
exist in the real world
right now hidden variables theories are
philosophy
you don't specify what the hidden
variables are you don't say how they
work you don't have an equation i look
at your path integral the key term in
the in your path integral or at least as
of 2020 is
quantumness
which is a placeholder for something you
want to put there at some point into the
key term because that's what you want to
minimize nature wants to minimize
quantumness according to you
this is not theory
this this is not even the outline of a
theory this this is a philosophy now
regarding you you're talking about the
wrong paper i hope
if you excuse me um for interrupting you
but this is indeed not a hidden
variables theory and nothing in the
paper claims it is you're looking at the
wrong paper
the paper you should be looking at is
called a local deterministic toy model
and it does have hidden variables we
explain exactly what they are and how
you specify what the hidden variables
are
precisely specified so you can control
for their state when you reset the
experimental conditions in your
experimental proposal so you know
exactly how to bring the hidden
variables to the initial state
that's a completely different that's a
completely different question you're
asking did i define the variables
right i've i've defined them i can tell
you what the distribution is
also i mean there's a reason the thing
is called the toy model because we we
made this up to prove a point namely
that those theories are not
conspiratorial
um you you said there aren't any models
you don't know what the hidden variables
are i can tell you what they are they
are random variables that are uniformly
distributed
uh in the complex disk with radius one
so you want an answer to this question i
should also add you know that what you
just said about there aren't any hidden
variables models um it's just wrong you
know it's not that my model is the only
hidden variables model that's super
deterministic
there are others and we have the
references in the paper and um you know
i i don't want to be too out to you on
this because i hear this constantly you
know people are always like super
determinism isn't the thing and they
never bother to look at the literature
um to see what models people have
actually worked with
so you've made many points give me a
chance to try to address not only one of
them but a few of them even if you don't
like what i said about the first you've
made many points in a row let me try to
address a few in a row as well before we
go back to this so let me do this in
order statistical independence you call
it a mere assumption i don't think it is
a mere assumption so let's try to
illustrate for the audience what it
means what this technical term means
it means that the thing you're measuring
does not change
just because you set up your measurement
apparatus in a certain way or another
for instance if you are photographing
the moon
statistical independence says that the
moon will not change will not do
something else will not be something
else
because you set your aperture or
exposure to certain values the moon is
what it is it doesn't depend on the
settings of the instrument you use to
make a measurement of the moon or to
take a picture of the moon
this is what statistical independence
means is it an assumption i don't think
it is i think the entire history of all
of science tells us that this is how
things work
reality does not change
based purely on the settings of what we
use to measure it what we use to
photograph the moon the moon doesn't
change because i changed the aperture on
my camera now you say that we cannot
carry what you call an assumption i
don't think it's an assumption i think
it's a very very solid observation very
self-evident observation about nature in
all aspects of science but okay i will
continue to call it as call it an
assumption you say we cannot carry that
assumption from the classical world to
the quantum world that carrying this
thing over is arbitrary but you are
carrying something over from the classic
world to the quantum world you're trying
to carry and you don't like the isms so
i'm not going to call it physical
realism i'm going to specify exactly
what it is
you don't want to carry the notion that
objects have standalone sorry you do
want to carry the notion that objects
have a standalone existence that they
are what they are irrespective of what
they are whether they are being measured
you want to carry that over from the
classical world to the physical world so
i don't think you can have the cake and
eat it too either you don't carry
assumptions from the classical to the
quantum or you do carry them and then
you ought to carry a
statistical independence because it's
one of nature's most self-evident givens
now hidden variables themselves unless
there is something very new that you're
springing on me right now
they are not defined the experiment you
have put forward is based exactly on the
fact that you cannot reset the
experimental conditions to what they
were in the very beginning when you do a
new series of measurements on the
quantum system that's why you talk about
having to cool everything down have to
reduce it having to reduce the degrees
of freedom of the measurement apparatus
having to do the series of measurements
very quickly in succession because
you're afraid that whatever state the
hidden variables are in they may drift
all that is based on the notion that you
don't know what the hidden variables are
and we don't need the hidden variables
for anything else in nature look let's
let's take the other variables the
unhidden ones the ones we know basic
properties of physical entities let's
take mass charge and angular momentum
if we remove them from the picture
we cannot account for any of the causal
chains in nature not only in a quantum
experiment anywhere you take mass away
you cannot account for inertia you take
angular momentum away you cannot account
for magnetism you take charge away you
cannot account for electricity but you
take the even hidden variables away
nothing changes we are still fine so i
think they are pure theoretical
fantasies unless and until you can see
exactly what they are how they work how
they can be measured
and how they can be falsified because
the experiment you have proposed
by construction cannot falsify the
hidden variables hypothesis and i can
elaborate on this at length to explain
why i'm saying this but it okay i'll
stop i spoke enough yeah we'll let
sabina respond
well i noticed in your
blog post or whatever you want to call
it that you were trying to criticize the
experiment that i proposed um
unfortunately you don't seem to have
actually look at the original paper
where proposed the experiment you quoted
the paper from 2019 which refers to a
paper from 2011
i believe in which i have
explained exactly how you can circumvent
this problem that you don't know how the
hidden variables
um
the state of the hidden variables for in
in the prepared state you make repeated
measurement on the same system
and then i made some estimate for um you
know
what the size of the systems would have
to be how code it um should have to be
and so on now you're complaining that
you can't falsify it but of course if no
one makes the experiment to falsify it
and we're not going to falsify it no no
my my point is the experiment cannot
falsify it
so sabine can you respond to this
unfalsifiable claim of the model
yeah i mean you you propose a model um
and then
you make a prediction and if the
prediction isn't correct
then you falsified the model
that's not how it will work of course
that's not how it will work yeah well
that's quite possibly the case
i can explain how and why
you know if this is a general criticism
about
falsification we can have this argument
you know we can argue that no theory has
ever actually been falsified if that's
what you want to say i would actually
agree with this you know the ether has
never really been falsified blah blah
blah blah as i've said a few times we
don't really falsify theories we
implausify them until people give uh
give up on them but i think that's kind
of a really um tangential point
so can i elaborate on why i
made that claim so let me
first we have to explain the experiment
a little bit so so people can follow the
experiment is the following
since we do not know what the hidden
variables are
we have to adopt certain procedures to
minimize the chance that whatever they
are their values can drift because the
experiment is based on the following
if you have a quantum system
and you make a series of measurements on
that system
according to the bond rule of quantum
mechanics you have a certain statistical
distribution of measurements that is not
deterministic
if super determinism is right if there
are these mysterious hidden variables
then the series of measurements will be
determined by the system's initial
condition
so the experiment is based on the
following idea
even if i don't know what the hidden
variables are and i cannot know how to
restore the initial conditions of the
system because of course we need to
restore the initial condition of the
hidden variables too
even without knowing what they are
if i cool down the system and i make a
fast series of measurements
stop and immediately do a next series of
measurements after returning the initial
conditions as best as i can
and then do the same thing and do
another series of measurements
if super determinism is right the series
of measurements will all be determined
by more or less the same initial
conditions if i do them in rapid
succession before the hidden variables
have a chance to drift in volume and i
will find
time correlations between the series
which would then if that's the case
contradict the bond rule
now
because the whole thing is based on
having to do these series of
measurements in rapid succession but
having enough measurements to find if
there is a correlation between the
series you end up in the following
situation
if and when the experiment fails and
validates born rule
one can always say well
i didn't make enough measurements per
series so i don't know that they
correlate so it's inconclusive
well then you make more measurements per
series
but then each series becomes longer
takes longer to make so it will take
longer for you to start the next series
and then one can say well it's just
because the initial state has drifted
i took too long to do the next series so
whatever happens one will always be able
to claim that the experiment is
inconclusive and doesn't falsify the
hidden variables why because it's so
loosely defined we are not saying what
the hidden variables are are and how
they work we are not seeing anything we
are just hoping that there is something
that somehow does what it needs to do
for
this picture of nature this metaphysical
commitment the fit that physical
properties should have standalone
existence to survive
well two things first as i already said
earlier you're talking about the wrong
experiment
i'm talking about the experiments you
talk about
no you were talking about a change in
the initial conditions i told you that
the experiment you should be doing is
repeated measurement of non-commuting
variables on the same state
that alone is sufficient in the 2019
paper i was talking about a simplified
experiment i mentioned this in the test
text
and i can explain why
i have reason to think that this is
probably enough
but i'm not sure you're actually
interested in hearing that
okay but oh i am okay good i'll tell you
but so let me make a more general point
which is that you can't
falsify
super determinism i totally agree with
that because super determinism is not a
theory it's a property of a class of
theories
what you can falsify are specific models
and yes you are entirely right those
models would have to specify what the
hidden variables are or at least what
their properties are if you don't say
anything about it you can't make any
predictions
so what are the hidden variables
well that depends on your model you know
that different models that people have
put forward i would say that at the
moment they're all unsatisfactory
so according to your model to your model
what are the hidden variables in your
model
in in the model which you already
complained about with the path integral
we explained this in the paper the
hidden verb
the hidden variables are the degrees of
freedom of the detector which are not
the measurement setting okay and now i
can explain to you
why i think that makes sense because
i have a background as a particle
physicist okay so i i don't like the
idea of introducing new degrees of
freedom and throw them over the already
existing elementary particles in the
standard model
you know this whole problem you know i
get the impression you have some
background in particular so this is not
a good idea
however
we know just empirically
that the measurement setting
affects
the average value of the distribution
that's bounce rule okay so that's the
measurement setting
you mean like
like the angular momentum you set
to affect the distribution because
everything will fall along the
eigenvalues of of the detector
basically yeah i mean i mean something
much more
simple if you want to calculate the
probability of a measurement outcome you
have to say what is the thing that you
measure right otherwise how are you
going to project it on the eigenstates
okay so so that's that but this brings
up the question like what's with all the
other details of the detector what
happened with them like a detector is
not just a measurement eyeing state it's
a complicated big thing that has many
uh degrees of freedom
so um the model that i'm trying to
develop which is the thing that you're
complaining about with the quantum nurse
and that's that's the
you know that that's the
discussion in the paper where i say this
is the part which i haven't figured out
is exactly how those degrees of freedom
enter the evolutionary
but this is the idea so the degrees of
freedom of the detector
except for the for the measurement
setting itself are the hidden variables
and now once you buy this and i i i
agree with you that i don't actually
know exactly what the evolution or looks
like
you can very precisely estimate how long
it will take i mean maybe not as
precisely as i'm hoping but in principle
you can estimate how long it would take
for them to change
and that's why i think the the simpler
estimated in 2090 papers probably
sufficient
okay i i i will work with you i'm not
i'm really not closed-minded about this
but
there are things about this that
normally would
trigger your worst part
and in this case it doesn't and and it
still triggers mine
um
however complex the experiment or the
the measurement apparatus is
if we are talking about the local hidden
variables
what matters is
what the thing measured interacts with
the thing measured say you're looking at
spin of an elementary particle
the thing measure measured this timing
so it has
an interaction with a
tiny measurement surface
of the same order of magnitude as an
elementary particle
everything else in the apparatus is
about amplifying what's measured say
photo multipliers
sending that signal and then displaying
a way that is
cognitively amenable to a human being
but the measurement surface itself is
tiny so
whatever is going on in the other
degrees of freedom of the measurement
apparatus
shouldn't have a local causal effect on
what happens on on the point of
interaction right
so i think we may just disagree on what
we mean by uh detection or measurement
process um i would say that the
amplification actually is the
measurement like that's what what we
need to convert a teeny tiny thing like
single photon going through a beam
splitter into something that we can
actually read out and normally this
process is described by decoherence
and that's also an interaction with with
many particles now i actually do think
that this process of the coherence that
zurich and z have
gone on about
captures
some part of the truth you know it tells
you how the environment selects the
pointer bases
but it doesn't tell you how the outcome
of a measurement
is always a detector eigenstate in the
normal declarance paradigm you always
end up with a mixed state i mean
generically unless the state happened to
be a detective state already and so what
what um super determinism does for you
what the violation of statistical
independence allows you to do is it
allows you to write down
a local evolution law that will bring
the initial state into a detector
eigenstate
i agree with what you often say that
this notion that super determinism
validates the whole of science
that's nonsensical
i agree with you there
but what you just said that the
amplification
of the original measured signal
can determine the measure outcome
now that sounds spooky to me
because you're saying is that okay there
is there is an interaction between the
system measured and a measurement
surface which is tiny everything else is
just simplification and
transmission and displaying
the result of that measurement outcome
but you say something
causally efficacious happens in that
chain of amplification
that actually
determines the outcome of measurement
not the interaction on the measurement
surface but the amplification of that
it's like the photo multipliers to give
me a different energy reading from my
tile calorimeter
now if if that's the case then i have to
throw away all my experiments because
what i'm seeing is not the result of
measurement it's something the detector
has done and distorted everything
how do you reconcile this now
we have to assume that amplification
does not distort the result of
measurement so if you measured angular
momentum plus one in a certain direction
then then that is the reality of what's
measured and not something engendered
by the photo multipliers or whatever
whatever amplification system you used
in your detector
yeah i'm not sure i understand the
question like so i mean you measure some
variable you measure the spin you get a
probability distribution at the same as
in quantum mechanics
okay so what those other degrees of
freedom of the detector do for you is
that they
um decide
which the outcome is
so it doesn't they don't change the mean
value
the average bonds rule that's
what you need the detector either states
for
they just they're the random variables
that decide what what is the actual
outcome
then i go back to my original point
how can all this complexity of the
detector
influence the measurement the
measurement outcome if the actual
measurement happens on a surface area of
the same order of magnitude as the
elementary subatomic particle that is
being measured
well it just doesn't as i said i i don't
know what so you think that an
interaction with a single particle is
the measurement
no i'm saying it's not
then whatever you're saying
you're saying that
the the settings of the detector
determine the measurement outcome in
other words the settings of the detector
change the thing that is measured the
setting of the camera changes the moon
when i photograph the moon although i
know it's a classical intuition you
don't want to transfer it but
essentially for people to follow us
that's what you're saying
the thing that is measured
changes
depending on how i set up my detector
no the thing doesn't change
as i as i said i i don't want to
introduce any new degrees of freedom
so i think that i think the point where
people get confused is that they think
the hidden variables
in burst theorem or really in all of
those other theorems are properties of
the prepared state they're kind of
little additional degrees of freedom
that sit inside the particle or
something and if that's how you
interpret it then you arrive at this
weird conclusion that
the measurement setting at the time of
measurement changes something about the
particle and actually must have changed
it earlier
but this is just not what the hidden
variables in both theorem are
the hidden variables in bell's theorem
are that what determines the outcome of
the measurement so if i only give you an
initial state of a particle with
whatever variables there are if you want
to add more or you just only take the
normal ones that doesn't determine the
outcome you also need the evolution law
so what i'm saying and this is why i use
this carefully phrased sentence in my
video which you just threw out
um that what the particle
does
depends on what you measure okay and
what this refers to what the particle
does concretely i'm referring to the
evolution law
so if you look at for example if you had
looked at my toy model paper you would
have seen that this is exactly what the
evolution law does
the
measurement setting is in the evolution
law
so i have a quick note a quick note
bernardo that may help so instead of
saying you're saying and so on say are
you saying because this way we can find
out if there's agreement no i'll go
along with her terminology
for the sake of the discussion
what the particle does
depends on the detectors settings
but the particle only interacts with a
tiny measurement surface on the detector
far away
from
whatever else is going on in the
detector
how are we to reconcile i mean isn't
that
this is what you need for for
to break statistical independence but
it's like saying that there is
a complex causal chain
between the aperture and exposure
settings of my camera and the moon
so that what the moon does depends on
the aperture and exposure i use on my
camera when i'm photographing the moon
it's a very complex cause of chain
because the interaction between the moon
and my camera is just the photons from
the moon hitting the sensor on my camera
i think we are being asked to believe in
in something very non-trivial
even fantastical
if we do not have an account that tells
us precisely how this happens
why this is possible
it stretches credulity uh sabine but
less than him theory
so
i think
we're not making any progress on this
question on what you mean by the surface
of the measurement i just don't know as
i just said uh
even normally in the normal decoherence
paradigm and so on a measurement is a
process with a huge number of particles
you know we're talking of the order 10
to the 23 or something anything that
causes decoherence
um so i'm not exactly sure where the
where the disagreement is now you're
asking
exactly how does it work
do i have a theory no i already told you
um
right this is exactly what i'm what i'm
trying to develop i'm trying to figure
out exactly how to write down the
mathematics
and also i should say that when you say
that this is what it takes to break
statistical independence that's not true
that's my particular model you know
there are other people who are working
on different model and they have
different hidden variables and
completely different ideas
so
you know even if you don't like what
i've been telling you because you think
i'm crazy talking about the degrees of
freedom of the detector which i think is
the only sane thing
to do
then please don't also throw out all
those other people's ideas because
they're completely innocent
no it's okay and there's nothing wrong
with work in progress everything that
has ever been created that's good and
useful and proven was once working
progress there
is nothing wrong with that whatsoever
i do feel that
you are very early taking on a very
strong
very committed even combative position
against almost the whole of the physics
community
but you and for other people maybe
before you have something that is more
substantiated i personally feel it
doesn't do service to the cause to come
out so strongly so combative before you
even know
you know within some
with some degree of precision what
you're talking about
that i don't think is useful but
early stage research
that's what everything has to go through
there is absolutely nothing wrong with
that now on the on the part of the
coherence
in the video you put out like three days
ago i think the 19th yeah three days ago
which is a video addressing
some experimental results
that suggest that quantum mechanics is
right that the different observers can
have different but
true accounts of the same series of
events that's a prediction of quantum
mechanics ravelli sort of
elaborated vastly on this
back in
and these experiments using the the
wigner's friend
thought experiment uh seem to have
confirmed that um your criticism against
that is that instead of
witness human friends
photons were used as observers
and your criticism was
well a photon is not a valid observer
because a photon doesn't cause the
coherence
but you yourself has acknowledged like
the fathers of the coherence that the
coherence doesn't solve the measurement
problem it's an operational useful rule
of thumb
uh but it it presupposes that which aims
to which it aims to explain which is the
existence of a
classical state around a quantum system
in a superposition
into which the superposition information
sort of can
speak metaphorically here so people can
understand the information of the
superposition can leak into that
classical world around it and therefore
in some sense become lost because it in
some sense diluted in the state of of
the surrounding environment
but are if you discard a photon i mean
we have detectors that are made up of
a small number of elementary particles
today
um and they are detectors i presume you
would acknowledge or or you have to give
a special place to human consciousness
like wigner himself once tried to do
so assuming that you don't do that that
you're not saying no you have to have
human consciousness to be an observer
i don't see why
you would establish a distinction
between a slightly more complex system
capable of the coherence in a photon i
think both are valid observers and the
conclusions of those experiments are
valid
physical quantities are relational they
are contextual they are not
absolute so
first of all you're throwing together
various different things maybe let me
start with the first thing you said you
were complaining that
i'm very
express myself very strongly i'm very
competitive or whatever so i have no
idea honestly
why you would say that
i've written like three papers in 10
years if that's what you call combative
i don't know what you want
people are working on
my video well my my
video is a summary
well i i really i think i only made this
one video about super determinism that's
a summary in which i'm trying to weed
out the most common misconceptions about
super determinism it doesn't actually
say anything particular about my own
work i wouldn't do this in a video
because most people wouldn't understand
it anyway so i find this a little bit
weird that you
would be picking on this now um your
other question you are asking about uh
my video which came out this weekend in
which i do not talk about super
determinism now you seem to be
criticizing me that i don't
that's a little bit weird like i can't
in in every video uh tell people what
what's the exact thing that i'm working
on at the moment and how this would
affect this conclusion and so on this is
just
nobody would be interested in it
okay so
it's correct that in this video i do not
talk about how this would look like from
the perspective of super determinism but
i explained this in one of my papers if
if you're interested i can
continue the link to this which is
actually the reason why i was um looking
at those papers to begin with i
appreciate it now
coming to the coherence again i just
don't know what you're talking about
like if you have a look at any
decoherence formalism it always involves
an interaction with some kind of
environment that has a lot of degrees of
freedom and a single photon just isn't
that environment that causes decoherence
i mean what's supposed to cause the
decoherence
my point is not that it should cause the
coherence my point is
why should it cause the coherence in
order to be a proper observer because we
have these interference experiments that
give us information about the
superposition states so the photon
doesn't need to decohere anything for us
to get information about what's going on
which is exactly what the paper by
priyati and others from from scotland
did but in your video you'd say very
explicitly the photon is not a proper
observer because it does not cause the
coherence and my point is why should it
need to cause the coherence we can do an
interference experiment and we can
gather information without collapse
while the photon is in a superposition
state and i'm bringing this up in
relation to our previous discussion
because it bears on what i perceive to
be the same metaphysical commitment
which is the commitment that physical
properties have standalone existence and
therefore they are non-contextual they
are absolute they are not relational and
it's the same topic that you addressed
in your latest video although under a
new name i don't mind that you bring
super determinism into it my only qualm
is
why
throw away
the entire experiment and the careful
work that was done about it i mean you
end the video with a big red cross on
top of the paper saying it means nothing
and you're doing that based solely on
this notion that well it means nothing
because the photon is not a valid
observer but you know since the advent
of interference experiments we don't
need the coherence to have an
experimental outcome why isn't the photo
a valid observer why isn't the photo a
good friend of wigner
of course you can make
all kinds of measurement on photons but
those measurements would never disagree
with each other like
quantum mechanics would just give you
some answers you know that where the
disagreement comes from between the
different observers is that you disagree
over exactly where the measurement
happens
but the quantum mechanical theory
quantum theory
tells us that different observers can
provide equally true but different
accounts of the same sequence of events
sequence of events
right that's it
we know that that's the math of it
that's completely meaningless unless you
explain what you mean by an observer
an observer is a any system that
interacts with with the thing observed
in a way that changes its state
well i would disagree with that
that i mean that's just in practice
that's not how we make observations then
what's an observer fundamentally
well that's exactly the problem that i'm
trying to explain in my video quantum
mechanics does not tell you what a
measurement is so according to you what
is an observer
well i i think this this whole idea of
the observer is kind of irrelevant as he
already said it kind of brings in this
idea that consciousness has something to
do with it um
i think it's entirely sufficient when we
talk about detectors uh and as i already
said a detector is anything large enough
to cause decoherence that does not mean
that i say the coherence is sufficient
to explain what happens in a measurement
i'm just saying that that's roughly the
size at which you would reasonably call
the finger detector
but if i can do an interference
experiment
and gather information about the state
of the photo entangled with whatever is
being measured and i gather valid
accurate information about that
superposition state
why is that not a measurement why is the
photon then not a detector
didn't it cohere because you haven't you
haven't collapsed the wave function
that's the whole point of a measurement
that you collapse the wave function
but then interference experiments are
invalid we should throw them away they
don't provide valid information
about the superposition state i don't
know why you would say that
because the paper you were criticizing
used an interference experiment to
gather information about the
superposition state and extract
conclusions from that well sure you can
do that i have absolutely no problem
with that you know this also i mean
you make it sound like i have a problem
with the experiment experiment is fine
you know i'm sure they they're great
people and they have a great laboratory
and they're all nice people and and what
have you i'm just saying this experiment
doesn't show that objective reality
doesn't exist the conclusions are
entirely unwarranted
well
that's that's the science press
objective reality doesn't exist exist oh
there's nonsense
let's speak technically the experiment
suggests that physical quantities are
indeed relational and contextual
you seem to dismiss that conclusion
no i have no problem with physical
quantities being relational or whatever
also i mean if if i may say we were
trying to talk about super determinism
and now we've we've drifted off to you
trying to criticize a video that i put
out on the weekend so yeah
okay what other question regarding super
determinism do you have bernardo for
sabina
i don't want to get too much uh air time
i have um my little notes uh here
um
okay perhaps we'll take an audience
question about super determinism i mean
unless you
have one ready because it'll take a
while for the audience to see this is a
bit of a delay
um
i think i made most of the points i
wanted to make sabine you have a
question for bernardo
well
i'm i'm really generally
curious why people are so opposed to
violating statistical independence like
this entire story about the moon and so
on
i think you are aware
that
this is using a macroscopic
comparison
for
something we only ever observe in a
quantum experiment right so of course it
sounds completely crazy
right so so i don't really know why
people are
so willing to throw out this option of
violating statistical independence i i
really don't get it
i i don't think it should be thrown out
but
to come out strongly and say
it has to be thrown out because reality
is that statistical independence doesn't
hold i think that's a very very strong
statement and it shouldn't be made
lightly because statistical independence
is something we have learned throughout
the history of science is applicable
uh and to now suddenly depart from that
there has to be a very good rationale
for that very very well substantiated
there's nothing wrong in being in a
minority position i am in a minority
position all the time i know very well
what that feels like but it's important
to be able to substantiate very well why
we are taking that minority position and
saying that everybody else is wrong i
mean
i didn't want to to pick on you when i
said that that you were coming out
coming across very combatively it was
just as part of your video you knew to
say that all those old male physicists
don't have a clue what they're talking
about something of that tone which i
like i like that tone but i think you're
exposing yourself now in this but in
this specific area of your work where
it's so early
but uh you know keep in mind you're
you're going against practically the
entire physics community here
um and you're going very strongly after
them
and
in you're doing that before you have
even the outline of a theory that can be
defined and you're asking people to
throw away
learnings you call them we call them
assumptions i call them learnings that
we have accumulated over hundreds of
years
and and i sense that you're doing that
because of a metaphysical commitment
which is the very thing you are on a
crusade against thank goodness you are
in a crusade against that and i'm with
you on that crusade and i feel slightly
betrayed
with your talk of hidden variables
i don't know where you're talking about
my metaphysical commitments i as i tried
to physically very
i i don't know why you were
now rotating back to physical realism
when i told you in the very beginning
that my problem is
that non-locality
is not in the measurement collapse it's
not compatible with general relativity
i'm trying to solve a
mathematical problem
and that's the only solution
that i think works
and now all you you talk about why i'm
so combative uh and so on and so forth
i don't really know why why
where this conversation is going it
doesn't really make a lot of sense to me
what is the disagreement bernardo
besides the strength which or at least
perceives strength at which sabino puts
out a position because to me that's an
ad hominem from my perspective do you
have an argument about the argument
itself
i think hidden variables at this stage
are fantasy and we have absolutely no
experimental reason to entertain them or
to
no experimental reason to depart from
statistical independence which has held
for 400 years of science literally
everywhere
we do not have a good empirical reason
to depart from that or a good empirical
reason to postulate hidden fantastical
entities that that that are completely
counterintuitive and for which we do not
have even an explicit theoretical
account
so i think the whole thing is a fantasy
that departs from empirical rigor
you know well i could likewise say that
it's completely insane to throw out
locality which has been historically
dramatically
uh successful
right
and also i mean about this you you're
talking about statistical independence
again you're using a notion of
statistical independence that we use in
statistical mechanics and so on which
just has nothing to do with this notion
of statistical independence that enters
spells theorem i don't even know why
people think they they are the same
thing
they're just completely different things
or maybe people get confused about why
that it just that it's called
statistical independence i mean we
already noticed when we were talking
about what it actually means to violate
statistical independence that you don't
even know what it means
you know right people write down this
equation they don't know what the hidden
variables are they they confuse
causation with correlation and then they
come to all these weird conclusions
about there having to be some kind of
conspiracy and so on and so forth now
look i'm a maths person okay so i work
with equations so all this kind of stuff
it goes right past me
what i want to know is can i write down
a theory
that's internally consistent i will
actually make predictions and now you're
asking you know why am i
saying something about it if i don't
have a full theory well that's actually
a good question and
maybe i should spend a minute trying to
answer it it's because i've seen from
what's happened in quantum gravity and
also in particle physics that this idea
to formulate a full theory that is
mathematically consistent mathematically
consistent and then you go and test it
just doesn't work
you need experimental guidance and so
trying to fumble together all the
details without any kind of experimental
evidence that you can use to build the
theory just isn't going to work and this
is why i've been going around for 12
years trying to convince
experimentalists to please stop doing
always the same belt type tests which
will always give the same result but we
already know this please do some other
experiment that could reveal some
evidence for those hidden variables and
i'm i'm very frustrated that no one
wants to touch it because everyone's
like oh super determinism oh right that
was this weird thing where you have to
throw out free will right so they're
afraid to touch it
i i i agree with you but i sympathize
with them
you have to propose a minimally precise
experiment what you have proposed so far
is so vague
you don't know what you're controlling
for
you don't know what the thresholds are
like bell's theorem right that's also
terribly vague no it's very precise this
statistic very precise well has bell
told you what the hidden variables are
in his theory no he hasn't right
but i have to do it
he said what exactly is the statistical
measurement the ensemble measurement
that you would expect in case the hidden
variable local hidden variables are the
case and the difference with what
quantum mechanics predicts so the
experimentalist knows exactly what to
measure under what conditions and how to
how to interpret the measurement but if
we if you're told well you have to cool
the detector down when you have to
reduce the degrees of fear freedom of
the detector and you have to make enough
measurements in rapid succession
experimentally experimentalist will ask
how cool
how rapid is rapid enough what exactly
do i need to measurement and what
exactly are the degrees of freedom that
i'm allowed to have if there aren't
answers to that question then it's you
know
but i do have answers to this question
in the paper that you didn't read from
2011 i've now said this a few times
there are numbers in the paper i've
actually counted the degrees of freedom
i've estimated the temperature and the
size of the thing and how quickly you
have to repeat the measurements and so
on
in the 2019 or 2020 paper it was not
there that's right because i've already
published this in an earlier paper you
know i don't like to plagiarize myself
and maybe i'm a little bit old-fashioned
but there's a reference in the paper
which uh to the earlier paper where you
can look up the numbers
maybe the experimentalists are also only
looking at your latest papers and they
are extracting the same conclusions i
did which is throw your hands up and say
what can i do well actually i'm actually
in in touch with um at least three
experimentalists um who have different
ideas of how to go about it so i'm not
completely
hopeless at this point that maybe it
will happen within my lifetime
okay let's get to an audience question
this question comes from gastronic it
may help me referring to gastronic
understand the discussion of super
determinism better if it is clear and
i'll you already outlined this sabine
but perhaps it can be outlined again
what is meant by the definition of
looking slash not looking at and or
measuring slash not measuring in the
context of the double slit experiment
that's what this person wrote down
well as i already said you know
in my mind a measurement is an
interaction with an apparatus that can
amplify
a small signal and that apparatus has to
be large enough to cause
decoherence but i don't think that the
decoherence is sufficient to actually
describe the measurement process this is
what you need super determinant for i
hope this helps
this question is to both of you comes
from salvatore pais
salvatore pius wants to know this isn't
specifically about super determinism but
salvator pius asks if
you all believe that there could be a
super force a force of unification for
all forces
that
and just so you know sal wrote down sal
believes that this super force quote
unquote exists at all points in space
and time at planck scales and is equal
to the planck unit of force namely c to
the four divided by g
which in his mind has shown that the
strong nuclear force equals the force of
gravity which equals the super force so
what is your take on this what is your
opinion on this salvatore pius wants to
know
bernardo do you have any
thoughts on that
and then sources are our models um
if you don't want to talk about a
talk about forces you talk about force
carrying particles and if you don't want
to talk about particles you talk about
field excitations these are models the
question boiled down boils down to
do i think we
will one day
get to
a unification theory
that
brings gravity into the fold of what is
today known as one of the 17 quantum
fields
do i think a grand unification will be
possible yes i think i think it will be
possible
it may not go along the lines of m
theory maybe it goes along the lines of
loop quantum gravity
but i think ultimately i think nature is
screaming to us that whether we know it
or not
there is such a thing nature behaves in
a unified way
um such that there are no building
contradictory contradictions in nature
so yes i think eventually something like
this will be possible
sabine do you have any opinions on
salvator pisces question
no i'd rather not uh
um
but um so i basically i i agree broadly
speaking
we know that
nature
has never shown any internal
uh inconsistency so at least when it
comes to the
problem of combining quantum theory with
general relativity there has to be a
solution to this um now as i have
probably made clear i think that super
determinism is a part of the answer now
when it comes to the unification of the
other interactions i'm i'm not that sure
i'm not sure we actually need it may or
may not work out in the end well i know
you both have to get going so thank you
all for being here thank you sabine
thank you bernardo for spending some
time with myself and with the audience
and perhaps we can go through that 2011
paper at some point in the future and
have a more
specific and constructive conversation
thank you so much
okay thank you guys
thank you
it was at this point that sabine had to
leave and so bernardo stayed behind to
take some audience questions one-on-one
okay radcapsul says
without thought there is no science if
one wants to apply reason and logic as
the scientific method requires one has
to first have one has to first know what
thoughts are and where they originate do
you agree
absolutely
and that's one of
the weakest links um
in in our epistemology today and how we
deal with our own knowledge
we are
will miserably lack insight
into the thinker
and we think that thoughts
are objective entities that have a
reality of their own
um independence of the thinker
and the thinkers hidden assumptions and
prejudices and commitments
and so on and so forth
gemson says what evidence or reason do
you have for meaning that consciousness
is not evolving
is not what
not evolving
um
i think the contents of consciousness
are evolving
our mental capacities are evolving
i think not so long ago not so long ago
there was
no
capacity for metacognition in nature
sorry it's my allergy
so the contents of consciousness are
evolving there are more insights there
is more understanding we
we have a better grip
on what's going on um we're still very
very far away from
a complete understanding of what's going
on i think we still make many many many
mistakes there are a great number of
things we take for granted that are not
true
i think we would be tremendously
surprised by the depth of our ignorance
if suddenly we became aware of it
but steps are being made we are not
where we were in the middle ages we have
advanced and
we've identified some common pitfalls
and we don't fall in those anymore we
fall in others still but at least in
some in some minds we no longer stop
man in blackened woods says question for
bernardo can you envision a way in which
idealism can be refuted or falsified
if one would prove
that um
what we call physical entities which are
entirely defined by physical quantities
like mass charge momentum so so forth
if one could prove
that those have
a objective and stand-alone reality
irrespective of
the observational context
that would
go some way
into indicating that idealism is
implausible
it might also go some way in indicating
that a great many things about cognitive
psychology are implausible as well
and some aspects of our colloquial
materialist understanding of the world
as well
so that that would be um one way
and as it turns out for the last 40
years and that was a discussion we had
today precisely the opposite is is what
is emerging
uh unless you give up on statistical
independence
and you
presume and you
how to say i want to use a word that
isn't disparaging and you take on board
the possibility that
the settings of the camera change what
the moon is or does
if you take that on board
then yes you can say well
physical realism the standalone
existence of physical entities has
survived these experiments
but you pay a very big price for it you
you have to part with something that has
been reliable for the entire history of
science
which is statistical independence or you
have to
take on board the notion that there are
countless real
physical
parallel universes
countless popping out every
infinitesimal fraction of a six second
out of nowhere for no reason for which
we have absolutely zero empirical
evidence that's another way to get out
of it so ultimately it gets down to a
context of plausibility
you know
and sabino zavina was correct today that
science is about
what can be rendered
most implausible or at least implausible
because you know whatever data you come
to me with
i can always say well it's the hidden
flying spaghetti monster that
manipulated the physical world from
behind the curtains you know i cannot
disprove that hypothesis
but it's very implausible and i think on
that same account
parting with a statistical independence
in the name of
hidden variables for which we have no
empirical evidence
is implausible and
multi-universe is popping out from out
of nowhere for no reason every
infinitesimal fraction of a second is
implausible
and what remains on the table is very
very very plausible completely intuitive
physical entities are the outcome of
measurement just as the indications on
the dials of a dashboard
are the outcome of measurement if you
don't measure the dials show nothing if
you don't measure there is no physical
world but what is the thing that is
being measured that's the question
that's where we are going to make
progress
if we read what 40 years of experiments
are telling us if you reheat that
message we understand that there is a
deeper layer of reality whose appearance
is physicality
but not the essence the essence is
something else
physics is relative to that deeper layer
and i believe we may even
arrive eventually
at a deterministic theory of nature
if we start investigating that deeper
layer
without holding on to our metaphysical
prejudices that physicality should be
the end of the story because it's
holding on to that
that will prevent us from making
progress
if we don't heed the results of
experiments but keep on fighting with
experiments
based on very implausible hypothesis
we will slow down progress we'll not
stop eventually this whole thing will
fizzle out you know fantasy doesn't
cannot last forever
um
but it will it will slow it down
digen
cppl wants to know thoughts on
yoshibok's theory of consciousness
that's a question for you i don't know
what progress he has made um since i had
an interaction i think with this joshua
on my forum years ago 2016 i think
but i think 2016 if this is the correct
your shabbah
i
i don't know what is on what is smoked
um i think it's nonsensical i think
it's equivalent to saying that if i
simulate kidney function on my computer
accurately enough my computer will
urinate on my desk you can only extract
that conclusion if you mistake the
difference between the simulation and
the thing simulated
if you if you forget to see that the
simulation is not the thing simulated
then maybe you will have artificial
consciousness in the silicon computer
but the plausibility of that is exactly
the same as the plausibility that my
computer will urinate on my desk if i
run an accurate kidney function
simulation on it
all right well great talking to you
again bernardo we'll talk over whatsapp
and if you don't mind you'll have to log
yourself out i can't kick you out
because i don't know how to do that
banning you
thanks for having me man it was a
pleasure take care pleasure's all mine
man
okay everyone
yeah some people want to know if that
was the salvator pious who asked that
question yes that's true he is indeed
real he's a
person he's a perfect
and jolly fellow we recorded some small
conversations already about 15 minutes
maybe 30 minutes worth of extra material
to go at the end of our conversation
once we do have our live conversation
because usually what happens is i
privatize the live recordings which i'm
going to do here and add extra footage
improve the quality add a patreon
request etc
speaking of a patreon request if this is
the sort of content that you enjoy and
want to see more of and you have the
means and the wants then please do
consider going to
patreon.com it's a significant amount of
work to put some of these on sometimes
they take weeks so for example with sal
i want to go through his patents to do
them justice and that's going to take
quite some time the reason that sal
reached out to myself and not others
will make sense once the interview is
conducted as well as the reason for
the interview being pushed to march will
make sense as well
if you're listening to this on the audio
platforms i know that right now you're
watching but if you're listening to this
on the audio platforms please do leave a
review on whichever platform you're on
whether it's itunes
google
spotify it
greatly aids the distribution i don't
think you can leave reviews on spotify
and if you're watching this and you had
no clue that there was the audio
platform versions then search theories
of everything plus whatever audio
platform it is that is of your choice so
itunes
pandora you can find it as well as the
links to them are in the description
generally in each video
okay thank you all for being here i
should get going
take care everyone thank you again thank
you
the podcast is now finished if you'd
like to support conversations like this
then do consider going to patreon.com
c-u-r-t j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l
that is kurt jaimungle it's support from
the patrons and from the sponsors that
allow me to do this full time every
dollar helps tremendously thank you